[Music]
hi I'm you Fink whoa and I'm here with a
meet Johnny a Google expert in Identity
and Access Management thanks for joining
me today me thanks for having me let's
dig right in
so with the increase in cyber attacks
recently it's more important than ever
for IT to stay in control of who
accesses company resources while still
enabling employees to have simpler and
more intuitive access to work apps and
data that's right employees that often
work outside the office as we know in
coffee shops hotels airports and from
home so it's important for companies to
make sure that employees access apps and
data securely so let's just say I'm a
chief information security officer and I
have a lot of employees who want to
access their apps from outside the
office like you mentioned and from their
personal devices okay so you want
employees being productive from anywhere
but IT wants to make sure that they are
controlling what data they have access
to so let's take this example you have a
sales rep using the personal device and
it's about to close deal you want it
done securely safely and successfully we
can see that our sales rep is using a
corporate laptop that's approve ite but
they're also using a personal tablet
device that hasn't been approved by IT
the sales rep wants to be able to use a
tablet to access CRM systems in G suite
and corporate IT has to allow that right
so the employee wants to use their
personal tablet and access work data
exactly but the problem is that personal
tablets don't have as many security
controls as the corporate device does
and so can you talk a little more about
the risk of that well the risk is that
if it attacker exploits the weaknesses
on this personal tablet let's say that
they use OS version flaws and things
like that they can get access to apps
and data that this shouldn't be able to
got it so as a C so how can I make
employees and a more productive using
these personal devices well as a first
step what you want to do is only give
our sales rep access to apps on their
personal device if they're in the right
context using Google Cloud access
context manager you can define a policy
for these personal devices to only allow
them to access some apps while the
employees in the office
so if you go to our sales rep in the
office they can now access their CRM
system and G Suite applications from
their personal device and from their
corporate laptop so that lets my sales
reps be productive on their personal
tablet while they're in the office and
can be on a secure network that's right
and so this is great
and for my employees that are working in
the office all the time but then what
about when they leave the office good
question it's common today for our
employees to be working outside of the
office let's say our sales rep goes to
the coffee shop and they log in using
public Wi-Fi this is a problem because
they may not be a secure network right
public Wi-Fi is often not so secure
public Wi-Fi might be secure but we need
to be careful otherwise attackers can
exploit vulnerabilities in these
networks to get access to users devices
or they could easily look over user
shoulders to see sensitive data or
password information yeah so the way
I've always done this is just by logging
into a VPN when I'm accessing one of
these networks
well VPNs might do the trick but they
can be one-size-fits-all and it can be a
pain for employees to log into we have
another way of giving context aware
access to applications using google
cloud using Google cloud services like
identity where proxy and cloud identity
we can gather information from the
employees context like the device
they're logging in from the type of
network they're connected to and we can
set up a rule that blogs access to
sensitive applications on personal
devices when they are in a situation
like this using public Wi-Fi so if our
sales rep moves from the office to the
coffee shop this triggers a context
change in identity where proxy and cloud
identity and when our sales rep tries to
access their CRM or G's suite app they
can access the app from the corporate
device because this is a more secure
device but from the personal device the
app is blocked because of this
heightened security need let me give it
a try all right
so okay so that's what here you can see
it's failed and here the access is
granted good
so as employees move around and their
context changes that changes their
access to different apps exactly so now
that the sales rep could still be
productive outside of the office but
their access to certain apps on certain
devices are restricted and as a see so
you can see granular controls to add
heightened security in some context
let's say your sales rep is closing a
deal overseas and needs to travel to an
international country that your security
team is deemed to be a restricted
country if the sales rep accesses their
app from a network like the hotel Wi-Fi
attackers may exploit vulnerabilities in
the network to access the sales reps app
and data all right so I should just lock
down all access to apps when employees
are traveling to these countries not
necessarily it's often the case that
executives need to be able to work from
these higher security threat countries
and they need to access some sensitive
data to get work done using Google Cloud
you can add an additional level of
security for high-risk contexts like
this an access context manager I can set
a rule that blocks all access to apps
except G suite Gmail from these
countries and only from a corporate
device why don't you give it a try on
the personal device but Ernie try
accessing Gmail sure I'm gonna flip over
to Gmail here and say I try to type in
Gmail and I hit enter and looks like
we're blocked you're blocked
I'll bet from a corporate device you'll
lose access to the confidential data
there's a no CRM access for me exactly
when you check your email they'll
continue to work great so now when the
sales rep tries to access this
application from the corporate device
everything works as planned and the only
app that can access is of course the G
suite app because that's what's been
termed to be safe so that means the
sales rep doesn't have access to all the
apps with sensitive data in this country
but they can still be productive exactly
so now even in these high-risk contacts
you can better keep employees productive
and your apps and data safe this is
great I think it might finally be time
to get rid of that legacy VPN
I mean thanks so much for talking to us
today and teaching me how to keep
workforce productive and secure my
pleasure you think